hey folks we're back with another episode of wild
ride with steve-o and I think this week there's
a lot of media paying very close attention
so how about we get right into it with the
light heavyweight champion of the world ladies
and gentlemen Jon Jones the champ is here in
Albuquerque New Mexico were parked outside of
John Jones beautiful mansions overlooking the
sound Sandia Mountains it's got a guest house
what's the Stephanie Lowe mansion ah probably
this place you bought this house from Holly home
I bought this house from Holly Holm and her dad
Roger yeah when it's been creeping up in three
years now okay all right yeah so what does that
mean that when she knocked out Ronda Rousey she
thought it was time for an upgrade yes I got that
great for her for sure she wasn't living here she
sold you the house yes yes I'm sorry yes she sold
me the house she's a real estate agent and if she
did live here that'd be pretty cool too it's a
good thing she's got a day job after the whooping
I gave her yes that was it was it was like if you
know if I got in front of a car you know like
it was the same so know how this came to happen
John we reached out to me last week yeah yeah I
I've been a big fan of the power of momentum you
know we have great ideas to not sit on them
but to just go for it and I have this group
called the Care Project where we are nonprofit
in Albuquerque New Mexico stands for community
appropriate relief effort you beat me to it good
job Steve oh yeah and I know that you've spent
time in Albuquerque I've been in several shows
here in Albuquerque which are awesome by the way
like two and a half years yeah 96 98 yeah man I
know that I see the turnout people that comes to
your shows and I know you got a lot of querque so
I just thought I'd give you a call man use that
momentum and just see what's the worst thing that
can happen you can say no right it was so awesome
I remember I was at the skate park I'm gently
trying to get some tricks and all the sudden my
phone's ringing in my pocket I look at it says it
says Jonny bones Jones I'm like dude I'm getting
a call from John Jones right now all right what's
up dude he said hey man like I got this new it's
new initiative this charity where we're cleaning
up Albuquerque we're doing all these things to
help out the people and and I wonder if you could
get behind it and I said dude why don't we get
together and and film something together to make
it happen I'll be there next week next week and
then that put that that was last week so I come
out here we have made news all over the place yeah
man you're many are worthy of our respect there
every Dave I just got out because the news people
were expected nah I just got a text from my guy
you know when I got a story I contact TMZ try and
I told him I said absolute exclusive human fiction
or said I am such and this got this got published
like minutes ago says wanna see steve-o Ollie over
the greatest MMA fighter ever good cuz TMZ sports
has obtained video of the former Jackass star
star boarding over John Jones at a New Mexico
skate park this week and it's both awesome and
terrifying oh yeah check out the footage Jones
laid down on a ramp and let steve-o skate over him
and the first attempt nearly cracked John's ribs
by the way if you're wondering why the duo are
spending time together in New Mexico it's all for
a great cause steve-o joined the UFC champ to help
his efforts with the Care Project raising money
and support for communities impacted by covet 19
pandemic in New Mexico steve-o was a massive UFC
fan and has been a regular at UFC fights for years
what that's big man absence in man absolutely it
felt so good to get to bring some acknowledgement
to the care project man and and to have you come
back and support and to bring exposure in such a
positive way doing a stunt and giving back to the
community it's gonna be huge but I really hope
this this cure project thing just takes off and
everybody in the community wants to be a part of
it at some point and then that's that's my goal I
want to be the biggest nonprofit in Albuquerque
and and have it to where every ever every other
nonprofit that needs anything whether you're the
Boys and Girls Club or not I'm not sure if they're
nonprofit or not but whether you're the Boys and
Girls Club or a food bank I want the care project
to have their hand in every company so that that
they need absolutely nothing I want to provide
for it for this whole town and this all came about
that night when you saw it you taking this spray
cans out of people major riots going on looting
people are just being disrespectful of the City
of Albuquerque and then you see on the news John
Jones in the streets and like just [ __ ] people
forcibly taking away spray cans from kids that
are like you know trying to destroy property and
saying look that's disrespectful to our city I'm
mad too but this isn't the way and like that got
the attention of the whole world yeah I think I
think what it I think it stood for an idea we're
saying people all over the world looting cities
and taken over police stations and and and I
think what the Care Project well we weren't the
Care Project then but I think what I represented
that night was an idea of of civilians standing up
and saying hey not in our city you know who knows
what could have happened in Albuquerque if the
care project wasn't created or that that message
wasn't send that that right people you know the
message that was sent was that you know we're not
gonna stand by while the police stay three blocks
away we're not gonna just stand by and watch you
spray paint and watch you whatever you want to
do the missions got really clear that there was
gonna be a group of men that's gonna speak up
and sure enough man we you know I've got 30 men
to go out and and cotton police are protest and
this was on a following night I was surprised
did you take spray can away yeah and then like
maybe like the next night like whatever it's a
couple days later I started on all the MMA you
know YouTube videos now you've got like a whole
crew of 30 people you see weapons you see like
route to here but nobody's messing with our city
tonight and I know a lot of people got a little
bit uncomfortable seeing that because it felt a
little bit vigilante yeah yeah so we we walked it
back for me to come out here and we what we did
was we went the complete opposite route the first
night we went out we had 30 men with us and we did
go out as a nonviolent group what we did also have
about five over 30 guys have their sidearms just
for security for the group members you're not not
to approach protesters you know were you worried
at all for your safety when you're out there oh
absolutely absolutely and people thought we're
police officers cuz we did some job jackets on
and stuff like that I was definitely worried for
my safety but we made it real clear that we are
nonviolent and that we were here with the people
we were they're a part of the protest but we also
wanted to represent our community well by having
peaceful nonviolent non non you know vandalizing
type rotation so and it worked it worked we only
had to show up one time as as over Watchers and
I think the message was sent we we actually kind
of apprehended someone that night and took
cans from another group of people that night
had searched their car for more cans and found
more cans we only had to do that one time and I
think the messages were sent that you know John
Jones and and the care group are out here and if
the police are gonna state blocks away these guys
will will do something to you themselves you know
we're not gonna hurt you or anything but a bunch
of crawfish CrossFit athletes and power lifters
and UFC fighters fighters you know yeah asking
you to not do that you may be may stay home I'm
surprised it took the kids so long to give you
as can I mean you could use like get over here
like yeah you're the older brother like hey
idiot you know it was a surreal moment you
know cuz every act of aggression or I've done
every eye I'm a very laid-back peaceful chill
do you know I never get confrontational I don't
like to argue so anytime I get that that feeling
of anger is it's usually in a UFC situation so I
hadn't I haven't I haven't been in a street fight
since Daniel Cormier I don't get in arguments
face-to-face conversations like this iam gran
and in the arena few years ago back and I'm sure
a year that was but yeah did it beat it was the
first one yeah the first fight yeah the first time
we faced off we worked forehead to forehead and
he shot me in the throat I ended up pushing him
over tackling him off the stage it was crazy yeah
I thought I thought the best of them he ended up
taking off his dress you and winging it across the
room trying to hit me in the face to get the last
lick and ended up hitting a female reporter in the
head instead it was crazy that's not good moments
later we go backstage and we get in this heated
argument and then that's when there's this famous
hole are you still there [ __ ] hey [ __ ] are you
still there have you ever heard that light nah
he's like I just want to [ __ ] spit in your
yeah yeah their form is like I will end you I
was like I absolutely kill you yeah if you do
that a sec you think I'm just gonna sit there
let you kill me Jon Jon's whole argument with
it was clearly by 2016 or before right because
I only really became like the die-hard UFC Fan
like around that time and since and I guess that
doesn't make me very diehard but man I don't miss
a fight are you you draw a Yuna you DC cool now
or just yeah I respect DC III I think he's an
outstanding man I I think he represents himself
very well I think he represents african-americans
very well I think he reps that you will see very
well being a father being an athlete you know he's
very well-spoken he's a great commentator his
analysis of fights is just so fantastic and for
that matter everything every one of them every
Dominick Cruz Joe Rogan they kill it they got
the best chemistry when the analysis just
the knowledge like okay now he's gonna like
you know you're gonna swivel his hips is gonna
who knows what they're watching yeah they're so
articulate and so like just impressive I could do
that like a kick and then a veni punched him four
times I would be being biased and siding like to
subconsciously siding with people like oh could
you have her like scotch people and stuff that's
why I would go over especially if you knew him
too yeah yeah exactly it'll be you know obviously
I was rootin for you're super articulate guy have
you thought about getting on the commentary
scene before Jon Jones gives his commentary
on commentary let me tell you about what I'm
wearing on my right wrist it's called a whoop
strap and it's a fitness tracker which provides
more insight into your overall health than any
other device out there this thing works with an
app and it's constantly giving me information
like for example sleep the exact amount of REM
sleep deep sleep how many disturbances there
were plus all of my exercise activities my heart
rate variability there's so much information and
I'm able to have groups of my buddies so that we
can compete over who's doing more exercise who's
sleeping better who's in overall the best health
it's just plain killer and I have no plans of ever
taking it off because I don't have to you see I
carry the charger in my pocket at all times it
slides right on and boom it's charging the thing
is just so killer I cannot recommend it enough
it works as a membership service gives all kinds
of cool perks like the strain coach the recovery
coach constantly giving you information about
how you can improve your health and if you go
to whoop calm that's WH Oh Opie calm and use the
promo code steve-o you're gonna get 15 percent off
at checkout again I can't recommend it enough so
again it's use promo code steve-o at whoop calm
for 15% off at checkout and you gonna thank me
for it now let's get back to the commentary no
no not at all why's that um I don't know man I'd
like to act I like Jews well I think that that's
sort of like you know pushing the same boat yeah
give it a shot man yeah I wouldn't be buying I
wouldn't mind doing something like doing like a
guest hosting gig or something like that but well
the most part I've always had it in my heart to
be in a movie I think my daughter's really proud
and I think that a little bit of commentating
would like help facilitate that you know it's
in front of the camera not fighting like would
it be like an action movie were to be like the
notebook I could see myself doing something like
a military role to start off just to get my feet
wet you know being able to wear like a military
uniform and be like an elite squad member of some
SEAL team or something like that I would love
that you know some real simple lines for just
to start me off and you know I think I think if
you're right down my alley I mean it's always been
a dream would be worried about though that I see
that most people that get into acting don't really
do well in their next fight so would you want to
wait till you're done fighting is that fair to
say I mean their correlation between people [ __
] around with with anything that distracts them
and that's probably a good reason to not even be
worried about the broadcasting in a commentator
yeah because it's like you know let me keep my
head in the game and not you know I I think that
I think that I will when I do get into acting
I would want to do it wholeheartedly I'm not I
would like to take like a movie role like sometime
soon just exist to try like being an extra having
a small role like I was just saying but to like
actually pursue a full-time is one I think I'll
get into that when I retire I want to hire an
acting coach and and do it take the same approach
that second to my mixed martial arts career and
to acting and with commentary another reason why
I haven't really tried to pursue opportunities get
into that and it could be a subconscious thing I
don't want people to get into my psychology too
much while I'm still an active fighter or I feel
like if you're smart enough you couldn't listen
to I always say if you want to know what's in a
man's head you just listen to what comes out of
his mouth and you'll start to get a true sense
what's going on in his head right that's going so
so so meet me explaining the way I see positions
and things like that I think I'll give people a
little bit of my sight yes exactly I want them
to think that it's just my long arms that makes me
win yeah all right so we come up to your house and
by the way it's so hilarious like camped out in
front of John Jones and I was so many things so
much more friendly right now and and right when
we pulled up parked the RV get out and you're
covered in sweat you just got back from mountain
biking with your endurance coach your endurance
coach says to you yo man our top speed was 39
miles an hour and and that's like biking on a
mountain bike down a mountain yeah it's pretty
dangerous for my experience level for sure I
mean there was there was some cyclist who would
probably go way faster than that but to be on
mountain bikes and me bein an amateur that was
the fastest I had ever gone and baby steps man
so yeah I loved it my first thought was like dude
that guy's on your team he's putting you in that
kind of danger I'm serious but I thought like
should I see John think about firing this guy
what we've been realizing is that biking mountain
biking and biking it correlates it translates over
into fighting a live wrestling and I'm actually
trying to get my little brother Chandler Arizona
Cardinals football player to start my mountain
biking a lot more I'm noticing that I'm spending
so much time and this hunched over bent over
position where my knees are kind of bent I'm
not standing upright and and it's a lot like an
aggressive attack position like that's fighting or
shooting in for a double like dive or something
like that so I feel like my knees are getting
stronger and more healthy it's complementing my
power lifting a lot and I think what he's getting
I was like it's it's if you fall you're [ __ ]
oh I would be thanked for sure so it's not like
you're swimming laps or something like that like
well that's no it could be a career changer that's
another thing the hey that coordination type of
thing when you're on a mountain bike you have
to you have to be totally engaged with how fast
you're going is the gravel loose you know is it
gonna is this bike gonna tell whip on when I try
to turn this corner this Boulder is coming up in
my left I got a jump and I gotta make it so it's
it's you you know you're your eyes and your and
your your brain and your body's all moving it's
it's so good for you man is that like fast twitch
muscle twitch muscles reaction time I think it
enhances so much I really recommend it alright
I think you'd like mountain biking luck Steve
cycles you know I mean you've been BMX in your
life why do the the road bike okay it's cool
it's but I didn't you never got into grinding
and bikes okay skateboarding I got a question for
you okay I can't read what just went through this
trip I came to the mountain bike where we're
here we'd like John Shuster of course is good
so then the next morning we wake up and it's
like we go to Jackson wink this is like the most
Jackson wink is your training facility steered
your coach we train it's I it's I think American
Top Team is pretty well known but Jackson wink is
we've been up there we've been up there for a long
time there are some teams that are definitely
as known as US and they're getting really big
and as of today we may not be the best team in the
world but over the last decade we have been in the
top three top five and so yeah we're legit we got
guys from all over the world that comes in and and
Holly home we got we got some new guys that are
coming in air and pìkô a guy named Patchi these
were Bellator athletes that I think could compete
for the UFC world title right now yeah I saw her
running in and she was just dripping sweat and
then she went into kicking Steve's ass and then
she went into like hitting bags and [ __ ] well I
was home she trains about five or six times every
single day I hear there's like a disease like
a workaholic disease where people like worked
themselves into she could have it man she is she
she runs she told me yesterday she has this goal
to run a hundred miles a month a hundred miles oh
man she runs and for UFC fighter I think that's
ridiculous she does CrossFit type workouts she's
in shape she hits rip Winkeljohn three four times
a day sometimes and she's always in the gym and
she's very humble she's very humble in it see I
respect that the most about Holly Holly's one
of the most recognizable people in Albuquerque
so everywhere she goes in Albuquerque I'm her
cameraman automatically look can you take a
picture of me and Holly no really man people love
her here she had a parade 27,000 people showed up
to her parade after she beat around the Rosie yes
and the way she just so gracious with every single
fan man it's it's really it's really special how
she does what celebrity we got we got some of them
some of the news that we made since we've been
here like Holly that was one that's out all over
the place so then we go from the gym when we go
to Walmart we buy like like two thousand dollars
worth of towels underwear toiletries all the stuff
works yeah and would you go around gave it to ya
we got to go to tint town this is a place I've
never been more just tent town was next to the
skate park where we did the terrifying ollie oh
yeah and then we went from there to go jump off
of I want to go jump off this building back when
I lived in Albuquerque it was a big deal for me
this three-story roof and off the roof I did a
front flip into five feet of water and almost
25 years later I asked myself could I do it again
and I didn't want it I'm glad I did and I came out
here to help the City of Albuquerque so we've got
this one frame sequence of like one photo of the
building but I'm there there there there's like
ten of me doing this front flip off the building
it's incredible and to help the Albuquerque Food
Bank up shout out to wolf Fox Photography by the
way all Fox yeah what are you gonna do with that
poster do you I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make
card stock eight by ten sign every single one of
them and sell them on my social media platforms
and 100% of the proceeds go to the Albuquerque
Food Bank because people have been listening to
this guests have heard me say it breaks my heart
that with the corvid pandemic the people like our
food insecure the idea that people can't eat like
I want to do something and so finally here I have
this initiative I think that I might be able to
some of those autographed pictures potentially
raised like a hundred thousand dollars for the
Albuquerque Food Bank what do you guys think at
home you guys gonna buy a single shot and be
people at the same time yeah I know that Tony
Hawk raised a hundred and twenty-five thousand
dollars doing exactly the same thing I'm just
copying Tony Hawk's model and and he did it for
a cove it wasn't food bank specific but it was a
cove aid relief in general they say if it's not
broke don't fix it alright tell me about your
relationship with Tony Hawk you've mentioned
him a few times I love the guy before I talk
about Tony Hawk let me tell you about what I'm
doing right here I'm harvesting my pubes and you
see I've been collecting my pubes for just about
two entire years so that I can make a Sasquatch
suit out of them well you know shaving my pubes
got a whole lot easier once I was introduced to
manscaped no more nicking my balls bleeding from
my privates now perfectly comfortable cut free
and grooming is a treat plus you know they've just
launched command scaped in canada so all you hairy
Canadians can get your act together a girl doesn't
want to see that bush you gotta get down there and
groove it yeah plus I'm never gonna have any hair
coming out of my nose or my ears because of the
manscaped weed whacker yeah if you don't have man
escapes lawnmower 3.0 and the weed whacker then he
just gotta get your act together and it's easy to
get it too because if you go to manscape dot-com
use the promo code steve oh you're gonna get 20%
off your order and free shipping and I'm tellin ya
if you if you're cutting your balls the way I used
to man life is gonna be a lot better once you get
into the manscaped way of life so enjoy and one
one more time manscape comm used the promo code
steve-o for 20% off your order and free shipping
now let's talk about the Birdman what is it about
him that inspires you I mean he's just such an
icon he's such a legend of course I'm just a fan
and having grown up in a skateboard and it's a
good dude and our jackass family came from the
world of skateboarding and going back to the very
beginning when it was just a little skateboard
magazine any time that any of us ever reached out
to Tony Hart to ask him to do something without
question a hundred percent he was there he did
it and and sometimes it involved like making
fun of him like he's just like he's very like
self-deprecating he's he's happy to be the butt
of the joke he just doesn't take himself seriously
and I mean like and we can help each other
sometimes he reaches out to me hey do you know you
want to be a part of this thing always a hundred
percent yeah and vice versa so we just have this
relationship hey that's cool and I really our
relationship is like that it's this fantastic like
the these worlds collide because like when I'm
jumping off that building yesterday John Jones
is flying the drone Charlie's the drone camera
back Joe is that a Mavic - I got this we had local
Albuquerque news crew following us around - so and
and John's like John says to the news guy hey man
this jumping off the building thing probably goes
probably not legal and and we probably don't want
you to cover it because we don't want to reflect
badly on the care project and I'm like cool this I
got this I'm taking responsibility for this and I
didn't even know that I thought that was something
separate from the whole help Albuquerque and it
turns out that might be the biggest oh yeah stunts
is what put you on the map first place so for you
to come back to Albuquerque where you grew up or
where you spent time and freaking jumping off a
building that you've done 20 it just it just it
came out great it wouldn't be Stevo coming into
town let's leave all did something wild all right
so I'm glad you did it man just gonna say you put
your health on the line to raise awareness but
now you say you're gonna do it no matter what
so I take that back I visited the building they
climbed on the roof I looked at it and I was like
man that's shallow I'm six feet tall and that
pool is five feet deep I'm not sure if you've
talked to anyone about your one two three and
I'm like okay I'd like I assess it and then I
don't there's no getting myself to do it and then
I'd but I just have this trick I count one two
three go and when I've done that I've never backed
out in my life of anything and we got to watch it
go once you started coloring it you know what
I'm gonna do that I feel that people can take
that and just implement that in their own lives
you know I mean just dare yeah one of my favorite
songs well it's not one my favorite something but
I I love that song I hope you dance by who I came
to think of the lady who sings it but I listen to
it all the sides like I hope you still feel small
when you stand beside the well I think it's a
great song cuz that's dancing that's like you
know I hope you take that dance I hope you ride
the bull' I hope you freakin you know what I mean
that's that's living that's a good and people can
live people can learn something from that you know
what he did yesterday was superhuman like climbed
up climbed down and then after we got done giving
away all the the care packages I said to you I
don't ever want to say this out loud but that
roof I told you about is point three miles away
John says let's go John Reed thinks it like man I
don't know if this is legal but dude it worked out
great man it worked out great I'm saying I don't
this is illegal once you're living in strange
times what's happening you're all grown up now
I don't know what's happening and then just to
bring it up to two currents and then we come
back to Johnson's he's got his his championship
room with every vote every fight poster ricktum
like they call out the victim hall every
fight poster just wallpapering the walls
his UFC championship belts like this is like and
this huge screen and I got to screen for you my
new project this multimedia comedy special
that I'm releasing like imminently council
real I got I got some of my buddies who wants to
steve-o's one of his last shows in Albuquerque who
absolutely adores this man and for medium blight
over my best friends and closest closest friends
to watch as screening and my theater with Steve
Hosting it in between sets and everything it was
mind-blowing it was it was one I mean yeah my
wife has always said she wants John Legend to
come sing at our wedding I mean that's that's
right up there I mean I don't know how we're
gonna top that that was amazing experience last
night Steve thank you so much well in that that
movie is gonna be nice guys I feel like I have a
me and my friends have a secret at the that only
we know in the whole world don't know about it
is going to be nuts when it was over we all felt
emotionally moved inspired in some way I mean you
were vulnerable you you you gave us visuals with
some of the stories we already know about you it
was a lot man so many different emotions it's it's
something that you that you can't forget and and
everyone has to watch it who are 18 and over okay
because there's so many important questions and
there's so many little things I'm curious about
let's start with your your characteristic your
trademark entrance of the to the I you enter
the Octagon crawling and then the fight starts and
you're on all fours essentially crawling when the
fight begins yeah yeah and and and what is that
about my first crawl not up into the cage but
crawl towards one opponent once the fight started
and that was with Rampage Jackson and then ran
space Jackson fight normally you see two fighters
they're always standing up and and you know John
McCarthy are you ready are you ready let's get
it on right and and both guys come skipping into
each other you know I feel like I was I was the
first fighter to ever crawl towards an opponent
while the fight the why the time sticking right
you get down sometime you look at the next guy
that cuts you off in line or something you just
get down crawling up to him so it's intimidating
so with Rampage Jackson I kept having these
nightmares that that I would get knocked out
and no matter how the fight played out I would
always get knocked out and it was always within
the first 30 seconds of the fight so you know
once you know I've run out he'd run at me Swink
a huge over here right the other he would throw
a right uppercut and then another dream it was a
left hook and I couldn't avoid this inevitable
knockout that I was going to experience in the
first round and you know I'm a big fan of sports
psychology so I call I called those Redstone
thoughts and I actually learned that from a shot
Evans you know when you have a negative thought
immediately cancel it with a positive thought you
know instead of thinking of somebody beating your
ass you think of yourself exhausted your winning
fights almost over just think something positive
and I just couldn't avoid these images and in
actual nightmares of rampage Jeffs and knocking me
out so on fight night I felt like I was gonna get
knocked out and I felt like this was coming for me
I felt like energetically like I was getting these
signals from a higher power that like John this is
gonna happen to you tonight and I couldn't avoid
it so I just had this super deep prayer where I
got down on my knees and I and I touched my body
from my head to my toe for the first time and I
pray this prayer asking God to just give me the
super natural like reaction abilities from speed
flexibility awareness and and as I was as I was
praying this prayer and touching my myself rubbing
myself and in meaning every ounce of this thinking
my life is on the line I noticed looking at myself
that I was covered in feathers I was covered in
white this nation it wasn't a hallucination and
it was it was it was real spoke to you it was
very real to me it was very real to me I could
see myself covered and like there was like small
feathers in between my fingers and I was covered
in feathers and they came up like to my neck and
my face was still like normal not in competitors
but my hands our feet were covered and I felt like
I was like this fighting thing that wasn't earthly
almost and I like felt this surge of energy power
for flexibility mental acuity and awareness and
sharpness that I had never experienced before
and I like jumped off my him my knees and like
landed a bull feet immediately and I was just like
whoa Wow I was just when just like my coasters is
looking at me like like they could feel like okay
he is pumped up and coach Winkeljohn is like let's
hit let's hit and immediately I kicked the pad and
it was like mmm and it like it like it was like
whoa and like my kicks were lightning fast and I
didn't need to stretch any more I didn't need to
warm up my lungs anymore my kicks were going up
high I was jumping higher I was kicking faster
and higher it was an unbelievable experience and
I actually was able to hang on to this feeling and
this illusion of myself being in this alter ego
all the way through the cave all the way through
my walk to the cage and and I felt like in that
Rampage Jackson five I walked into that fight
as this feather man for the first time and my
my idea to crawl towards him was the only thing
that had it happened in all my nightmares right
because in every place I started on my feet so
something just said good on your knees and crawl
up to him and then automatically the dream voids
itself of him knocking you out immediately right
so I did that and I got to kind of I don't know
fighting up fight an alter ego kind of stayed and
it was super powerful now to this day I say that
same kind of Prayer over myself and I believe that
that I transform it to something I love that she
got a million things like that you know when you
were in that fight was time slowed down for you
were you're kind of like this is what time things
went slow down but you you you get to this belief
place that you are that you are more than human
at the moment and then you believe that things
as far as just on every realm are not designed
to go against you at this moment's this is all
you're actually living in your actual purpose at
this moment this was exactly what you're designed
and born to be doing this is your mark and and at
this moment I'm being used by my higher power to
like a fuck-shit beautiful story very much I got
a question about the walk out mm-hmm with with
the music like I was so impressed when you had the
the song the Queen saw the song by the mousse yeah
like you know like did I get goosebumps from that
like what's the lyric I remember and when on your
walk out science second dude it was incredible
the question is are our fighters allowed to just
pick any song they want they have to license the
music so we are not allowed to come out to music
that has not been published by like professional
like label and stuff like that I think that's the
way it works so at before the UFC we would have
all the local kind of homies making your your
local your song or whatever and I think copyright
and lawsuits that people wanted to get a piece of
the UFC oh you guys played my song on pay-per-view
now I should get a cut and all this type of stuff
so data wise you said hey you know the ones they
I think they played the fight live when you come
out that night and then even reruns on TV on
television are always but the more known music
like Queen is gonna be considerably more expensive
to license I wonder how that I've never asked but
the UFC I work with a woman named Heidi who
works at the UFC offices she always does the
customizations of ourselves and and they can they
got some hella DJ's that can cut up any song any
three four five songs you want the walkout music
is just such a big deal in setting the tone for
the fight yeah I try not to I'm not I try not
to be too superstitious about you know music
and little things like that just because just
in case if something doesn't go your way say
the music stops or audio goes out or whatever
you're always able to get it out no matter what
state you know so right okay yeah I don't hang
on to the music too closely but every once in a
while I would try to put subliminal messages and
in the song that I choose but I don't allow it
affect my mental state that Queen use that Queen
tune right I've used it a few times I've used it
maybe two or three times since the first time okay
yeah but it's a relatively new thing that's great
I would normally be all over and but right around
flight time do my phone gets crazy that pisses me
off purse I don't like it either I don't wanna
mess with the fighter I don't want to contact a
fighter like we're feeling you get because we're
gonna distract a man when he's got a war to go
into it's like a one in you appreciate people
reaching out to you and saying good luck tonight
on the other hand you don't appreciate people
reaching out to you that you haven't spoke to
in a year or several several months right and
then they write you something of non substance
like kick his ass oh my bro you didn't write me
something right now I feel like my mind is it's
at a high capacity on fight day like a useful
useful useless [ __ ] [ __ ] it annoys me on
fight back say something and powerful impactful
said give me uh give me give me a scripture give
me something that's gonna like I can pull from
later on tonight don't say cookies ass cuz me
reading that thousand times today is not helping
any tax disruption I got better advice leave the
[ __ ] man alone let him concentrate let him be
with his team with his coaches and and and then
congratulate him when he wins yes yes yeah you
know I think that's what people are starting to
learn to do because I never I'm starving that's
it to not reply right before the fight and I'm
starting to get people get clever enough to write
me a whole month later after a fight they say you
know I see that you want to fight last month
I'm imagining things are finally starting to
calm down for you I wanted to reach out to you
and tell you that I'm so happy for you but those
people are the ones would get the best responses
from me because I'm actually in a mental place at
that point where I can actually give you my full
attention to everything like that but you know you
get it when you make a movie everyone your names
everywhere and everyone wants to be a part of it
at that moment and that's when unfortunately
you don't really have time to go into smaller
conversation the worst is my birthday you know
I've [ __ ] birthdays and holidays it's just
like it's so many people happy birthday happy
birthday and I know that these are people that
are wishing me well people who care about me I
wish you happy birthday response happy birthday
and I said something else the answer to something
else I [ __ ] hate because now I make a whole year
older we're drawing attention to have [ __ ] old
I am and my phone is bothering me all day with I
got more work to do replying to texts then then
I mean you're probably coming across as the most
I want to take it back to fight day like what
what's that like for you waking up but you have a
routine that you do every fight that day or is it
start before that or is it like we have pancakes
[ __ ] zoned out yeah my fight day I wake up I
wake up whatever my body looks me up so you know
sometimes that's one o'clock in the afternoon
sometimes that's 10 a.m. it always varies and
the coaches are always on standby we will have a
breakfast I never eat meat on the day of a fight
I believe that meat do you hide I jest really slow
and it gives you energy for like the next day or
the day after that day definitely not the same
day you know so I don't mean eat me on the day
of an event I'll eat meat Friday after my Williams
I'll have some meat probably like a fish or like a
white meat but the day of the fight I don't have
any me and I'll eat a lot of sugar I love slow
burning sugars I'll have in the afternoon and a
lot of carbohydrates throughout the day I'll chew
on some rice some yams you could never be overly
hydrated on Friday so I'm sipping water all day
long are you talking to people or you just like
don't know no I touch to very certain people on
fight day that's my wife I talked to my my father
I talked to my spiritual leaders spiritual you
know advisors does it suck being the last fight
of the night or would you rather be first and
get it over with I be in the last fight of the
night is all I have ever known it's all so mean
I came out the womb two or three fights in the
UFC I had before being the main main event guy
the goal is to be main event guy for the rest of
my career that's the goal the case I think that's
gonna be the case no matter which way it goes
let me ask this fighters we get the impression
are like really guarded about anybody knowing
what their natural walking around way it is
fighting not me but when they're on an interview
they're like school can you talk about what your
way now and they didn't ever answer the question
why do you do that I don't know usually it's a
psychology you don't want your opponents to know
where you're at you know you can tell a lot about
a guy based on where he's at you know if he's a
little tip he's ten pounds over if he's under it
shows you where his kind of mental is at at that
moment so does it also indicate how much power
might be depleted from him on awake absolutely -
yeah if I know I know you're 20 pounds over and
we're fighting in two weeks that's that's a huge
psychological health E mm-hmm and then and then
and then mentally to like you know when you lose
20 pounds in two weeks you're not gonna you're
not gonna be right not gonna be there so uh and
when you know your opponent's having a wig tough
weight Club I like to really get tricky with my
words and manipulative and really start to try
to pile on certain things bully the guy almost
it's trying to break him before the fight even
especially if they miss weight by 0.5 pounds Oh
that'd be bad who you talking about you know I'm
talking about didn't you say when these to move
your fighting DC your life you'd be the champion
of you know six point five no no no no so if you
fight for a title you have to make two or five
point zero if you're if you're fighting at U of
a UFC G's 205-pound exhibition then you can weigh
in at 206 okay so if a championship you gotta be
205 I remember saying that and I was like oh this
guy's down you know like you got it going on I
but I want to preface me talking about any UFC
fighter I am well aware that they can [ __ ] me
up at any time and so I'm very talking about them
very easily Scott like judgmental about it because
I'm like bro these guys will just [ __ ] kick my
ass so I just don't want to come off as talking [
__ ] no I didn't come across that way at all and I
do appreciate you having respect for the fighters
you know a lot of a lot of fans give UFC fighter
[ __ ] for a lot of different things then and
at the end of the day man we put our lives on
the line to be entertainers you understand that
you know I mean so there there's always a certain
amount of leeway that I'm gonna give fighters for
certain things it's a lot that goes into what we
do especially the keyboard warriors are just
[ __ ] a face made top top top top band but uh
you ever seen one of them in person you're like I
know you do no never in person no I've had maybe
one or two people flat-out tell me in person
I don't like you yeah it's baby happy once or
drunk in over a decade yeah and they're usually
alcohol involved yeah yeah but um I'm learning
to really appreciate haters because a hater is a
person that is emotionally involved they care all
right it's true they care and they can be very
motivating I've definitely been more motivated
by negative [ __ ] than I've ever been motivated
by a positive [ __ ] I'm the same way right I'm
saying right now though honestly being involved
with the care project and being detached from
UFC and trolls and all that type of stuff this is
motivating me way more than a world championship
fight I mean I've been title fights for so long
now I'd get what that feels like I know what the
after-party feels like I know what it feels like
to be called champ and looked at as the greatest
fighter forever I already been experiencing these
things for so long now that that [ __ ] doesn't
really tickle me anymore changing my changing my
life and giving back to other people and and how
do people say thanks for what you did for the city
last night of some of that my neighbors look at me
like like a person that they're incredibly proud
to be neighbors with that means so much more to
me than being a UFC champion and I'm so relaxed
that's so much more so much more fulfilling part
of me part of me believes that that's the way
it's gotta be I mean I know it's gotta be that
way because I i-i've for one I had to learn how
to separate my like personal identity from this
like steve-o character because like I'm just gonna
be barreling towards misery if I don't you know I
got to be able to be healthy without the career
you know have no future but I also know it's a
little bit like trickier it's hard it's easier
said than done you know yeah it's like you got
a legacy to worry about yeah and like when you say
oh that doesn't tickle me anymore it feels better
it feels better Stevo honestly it feels better to
leave my legacy behind for a while you know I'm
still 30 I'm still 32 years old and every time
I fight I'm taking such a risk yeah and we got
to talk about that too but first let's talk about
your Twitter and anything I'm just acknowledging
what's out there okay because did you let it you
let it ride on Twitter right yeah you let it ride
on Twitter and when do you tweet something it
makes news you know and there's been a lot of
people talking about UFC pay lately you know it
came out I think like last year there was some
like revelation in the media that it's you know
most sporting organizations pay their athletes
50% of all the revenue the UFC pays 18% right
can you explain what that means because I hear
you say that but I don't know what that means
I think take all of the revenue 250 all the
revenue that came in from UFC to this because
I've heard it said that the fighters don't see
a penny off the gate I know we make no money on
gate concession merch we do actually okay much
they give us a check every once in a while and
I'm not trying to goddamn that my employer but
yeah it's definitely it's definitely nothing to
right it'll pay a bill and definitely not see
so many John jokesters honestly people ask me
all the time where do I get the lion shirt with
the half lion half face and I just like honestly
it's a nice shirt you can get it probably in the
UFC website but if you're doing it to support
me that I don't get anything off that damaged
t-shirt you know see seven cents per shirt that's
Bobby if that I don't know I'm glad John said that
because I'm terrified to like you know mess up my
relationship to the UFC because I've [ __ ] loved
going to the fight and it could be said true that
there's no other game you know what are you gonna
make money going to Bellator well yeah that's
that's the most messed up thing about about my
situation currently is in any other profession if
you're unhappy with the way you're being treated
or the way you know you're being paid or whatever
you can just you know take your [ __ ] and leave
and and go to the next boss and see if they value
you more and in my situation I would be forced to
retire from fighting completely unless I wanted to
coach your own in gym you know my hands are tied
so that nobody's paying 5 million bucks a night
to coach a gym but I do believe wholeheartedly
that that you know the companies that own Bellator
and some of these other leagues do have the same
amount of backing financial backing that the UFC
had and I do believe that having John Jones would
be the new face of your promotion especially today
when I'm really making an effort for the first
time to really get my [ __ ] someone together I
do feel good my mass Twi has done a lot for me
man it set me free in so many ways it embarrassed
me it reality checked me it you know I've never
been on camera drunk for the public to see like
that it was it was humiliating and somewhat of a
bottom for me and and I'm ready to snap it into
high gear but um but anyways I think right now
is a good time for any company to have me for
sure understand my goal is to be an asset to any
company that that I'm a part of and I got a I got
a feeling that if I am able to get out of my UFC
contract that I would be huge for another company
for sure you know I just wish that my relationship
with Dana wasn't the way that it that it is
and it's like I get that you want to make these
hundreds of millions of dollars off me but if you
don't like me anymore if you sleep flatout don't
like me you could easily say what you wanted what
you want to say but I don't like he actually likes
me I've never had whiskey night and dinners and
and and [ __ ] like that and I was there man and
and you know I wonder because I believe that our
perception of something can be so wildly different
than the reality of I don't think I'm his favorite
person I think it's really clear when you watch
one of his interviews when I come up and my point
is that if if that's what it is if this has gotten
to a place of being personal then I would just
much rather work for a company where I felt like I
went home I'm home when I go to work the employees
and I do have great relationships well with UFC
staff great relationship with UFC staff but um you
feel like you feel like they don't really want you
there my perception is different and and when you
say I think Dana doesn't like me were reacting to
the same stuff we're watching interviews you know
it's not a personal conversation and I my take on
it it's not that he doesn't like I just think
that he's been put on the spot and John Jones
wants more money and then it's like oh and so
you're kind of at the negotiating table with
him in front of the whole world with the media
covering it all and so I don't think that it's
a question of whether he likes you as a person
or you know or is respectful of you I just think
oh now I'm being forced to negotiate on a world
stage which is an ideal and so he's just kind of
defending his position in a way that he I don't
think when consider personal on any level now
you're taking business and you're spilling it out
and - you know I mean that's just what's happening
yeah and so I think that he's I think he cares
for you very much when I hear him say he could
have been LeBron James I look at that and I think
that he wants you to be the LeBron James you know
I do believe that yeah I think I think he does
like you I think he does care about you and I
think that he's a shrewd businessman you know and
I think that he's got a monopoly on the entire
sport of MMA so he is in a luxurious position to
pay people what the [ __ ] he wants to pay him
he's basically the man he's the man and and we're
huge fans of his we're huge fans of yours and you
know I hate to say it to you but I don't give a [
__ ] who's fighting I'm never missing a fight hey
listen I'm a fan of the UFC myself the UFC will
go on whether I fight or not I got I got I got
nothing to lose being in the position that I'm in
you know I you want to fight soon no I don't want
to fight soon I don't want to fight soon I have no
interest in fighting in the UFC until I get paid
what I believe I'm worth and a lot of fans like
steve-o like just said we'll continue to watch the
UFC and support the UFC and I have no problem with
that I just ordered the last pay-per-view myself
but I think it's really powerful when you stand up
for what you what you believe is right and and I
think I think that I think that eventually the UFC
will realize that they're being stubborn they'll
realize that that they do have a special athlete
in myself and I really I think they'll realize
I think they'll eventually meet me halfway is
there a certain percentage point you want to see
or is there if you can wave a magic wand to get
your needs met what does that look like that's a
good question though but in it but and I won't get
into specific numbers I'm not asking for anything
outrageous and I know we're in a pandemic and
I know when you're multi millionaire you asking
for more it makes you seem like this greedy person
and all these type of things I'm very aware of all
this but I'm also very aware that that that I have
the voice in the platform to make change most of
the guys who are doing the absolute worst are not
in a position that they could say publicly I have
a second job I'm borrowing money from my parents
I know so many photos that are living in Jackson's
MMA gym because they can't afford to have their
own apartment and there were UFC fighters and
they just so this is sad and and if I have to have
a bad relationship with Dana sit out for two years
three years to bring to bring light to bring light
to what's happening let's not sit out for two
years to bring light to what's happening then then
this see these are the things that people remember
you for more than winning belts the guy stood for
the younger fighters legacy thing it is already
sealed the legacy with with fighting always like
who are you what are you stand for what are you
about and what way are you innovative trying to
change the world for a better what are you doing
because and I can't I gotta just stop me there and
say it again let's not go two years without fun
want to say that as it relates to what you're
worth there's something there big time and I
think that you're worth exponentially more now
and this is just my take this is just my take
but I think you're worth so much more now because
you've been in a place that's the worst place to
be for a UFC fighter where nobody even [ __ ]
necessarily cares that much because they know
you're gonna clobber your opponent so bad it's
just like okay you know we got a main event but
it's not even like really the interesting fight
because it's such a blowout it's so one-sided
it's like the problem that Amanda Nunez has right
now Mike Tyson Valentina Shevchenko Mike Tyson is
a little bit of different of a story because
they just wanted to see how fast it wasn't how
how explosive it was but Amanda Nunez Valentina
Shevchenko John Jones there's names I can think
of where it's like man there's so there's
they don't have a fight who do you put them
up against it's not even interesting right
and now we're I'm finally at a place where
there are big fights Dominic gray as General
Santos rematch I mean your last chance has
gotten people saying like John Jones looks human
in his last treatment he seems somehow beatable
I'm not necessarily saying I believe that's the
case but there's there's theories out there what
is that why are you looking like that I'm good
the city we are bad days at work I think that's
the best thing for me because now if the belief
is out there if it's in the consciousness that
John Jones is beatable then your pay-per-view
numbers are way up you are worth way more as a
potentially beatable fighter than you are as the
guy that you know it's gonna be a blowout I have
100% agree I think that I'm even more beatable
as a heavyweight and that's why I went to Dana
White looking for a raise Daniel Cormier got
a raise when he went heavyweight I was looking
for a raise to go heavyweight Francis Nagano is
scary you know there's a big chance that he could
break my jaw and I'm okay with that I'm okay with
that as a fighter I've whipped enough as that as
someone eventually gets me then we all have our
day I'm okay with that but I think that [ __ ]
with an increase of pay I think what about yeah
heavyweight the pay-per-view numbers are going
to go up inevitably more people are going to
watch but I think Dominic raise again absolutely
absolutely but the fact that the UFC wasn't
willing to budge at all they didn't want to
talk about hey listen let's pay you a little less
let's enhance this this let's make this their that
it was never zero no negotiation whether you go
heavyweight next whether used to fight dominant
rail snacks whether you fire yan block a [ __
] next you were gonna get paid the same event
the same amount and that's what made me retire I
just okay it was okay but but the percentage on
the pay-per-view you do get paid more if it sells
better I get paid more after more people start to
buy the fight so I thought on the first million
buys you know you get like a certain amount of
dollars and then after two you know after the
first hundred thought you giving them Sam that's
all incentive based sure so yes its back end like
I'm Jackass movies yeah what I wanted was just
the guarantee upfront to to go up a bit because at
the end of the day when I fight you know I don't I
don't know exactly what the UFC brings in but I'm
assuming it's somewhere wrong it's so funny how
exactly like the movie business this is because
there's two pieces of our movie contract there's
the upfront money what you're talking about and
then there's the backend money which is it once
the budgets been recouped and then tries to tell
you have to tell you have to trust them to tell
you how many movies are selling are you obviously
and we've got our lawyers do UFC no one questions
what was happening in the backstage is no one's
really auditing them to see how many paper user
actually did so you just they could say hey you
sold 200 bars this time and here's your check or
they can say there's been 700 bucks but it's
kind of like I'm saying like hey we're gonna
pay the same amount for jackass 2 then we do
for whatever you know right right of course of
course you should be always and and I think I
think you're because people are turning in for
the possibility that maybe Jon Jones is gonna
get beat especially a heavy well a heavyweight
more beautiful if it's got bit it's just simple
guys see they hit so much harder they hit so
much harder so the chances of getting knocked out
is higher but at the same time I've been facing
heavy weights for a long time and I do really
good against those guys I'm surprisingly really
strong really strong and I'm fast that I just move
well my body mechanics move very well so I think
I can do things that they just don't do and they
they just can't do it's kind of a question just
getting through the first round with him and
then you just get so tired well Francis Logano
it's very it's very simple get comfortable with
the worst-case scenario worst-case scenario is
he knocks you the [ __ ] out he possibly fractures
a bone in your face that's the worst case scenario
you get real comfortable with that idea and then
it becomes easy if he doesn't knock you out and
break your face you're smart you're fast you have
a chin you have great head movement you know you
can wrestle you can there's a lot of there's a lot
of ways things things can play out so I just think
about the worst-case scenario and get yourself
mentally to a place where you almost walking into
that like okay I'm getting ready to go out there
and this guy could possibly hurt me tonight okay
now that I've faced that I've swallowed that I'm
sure you have the similar conversation before you
jump off something you're like okay this could go
this way sure so that's the way I look at it so I
get friends about his dangers yes I believe that
he has a chance to knock me the [ __ ] out let's
sit let's say that out loud but if I don't get
knocked out I believe I win that fight I just
gotta get through round 1 and I wouldn't that
fight yeah how do you want to beat the gunner
you want to knock out or any any way you can
I just want to be the scariest baddest dude
on the planet and if that's Francis steep a or DC
yeah I just want I just I'm just ready to finally
stop playing games with greatness and just go for
it it's like John if you if you believe that you
have something that that is special that is even
a gift from your higher power then stop question
it because it's insulting it's insulting to you
that your Creator that you believe that he will
put limitations on what he's given you okay man
that's huge yeah hi then we're just about there
but I just said something that was a big deal and
he said I'm get comfortable with the worst-case
scenario mm-hmm is it an inevitability that you're
gonna fight until there is a defeat do you want to
try to get out while you're still undefeated my
goal is to get out while I'm still undefeated but
my goal is also to risk it all for my last few
fights I love it I love it I had a conversation
with Ronda Rousey on her YouTube channel and
she said some some pretty heavy stuff because
notoriously like it was well known that she took
the Holly home defeat real hard and she took the
the núñez to be even harder you know she was just
in a gnarly place and but then she came out of it
like a healthier person she told me she said you
know I feel like if I would have left undefeated
if I would have walked away with the belt you know
like that would have been selfish she says the way
I did it I'd say I feel good about I passed the
torch you know to there you know I didn't keep
it for myself and like I mean maybe that's where
you wind up when when you work through something
but my question is like if there is a defeat what
kind of by preparation what kind of like like like
like whatever head round walks that's a question I
feel like I have taken losses throughout my whole
adult life publicly to be accused as steroids
people you go from hero to zero immediately in
some people's eyes and even those you saw has
proven that that there's a reason for those
picograms and picograms gives you zero athletic
performance don't look like a guy was on steroids
even though I'm you daz a steroid user in some
people's eyes for the rest of my life which which
hurts me deeply honestly that's a defeat you know
I lost my mom you know that's a defeat I lost my
sister to cancer that's a defeat you know and
a hit-and-run it's a pregnant woman humiliating
and just you looked at as a monster you know to be
able to involved with something like that that's a
defeat you know so I've dealt with so much defeat
already and and I feel like my career has been
such a tremendous blessing already and everything
that I do in my career is just a cherry on top of
something that's already been great yeah if I were
to retire today they said that kid truly you know
came saw and conquered and you could retire yeah
it could be tired so I look at losing is at this
point in my life as is as John you are you're
already the greatest light heavyweight of all
time a fighter as a light heavyweight though
I'm the greatest light heavyweight of all time
and I don't think that's arguable right now so
I in my psychology I've already retired that and
and that UFC career is already on the shelf and
now I'm trying to focus on Who am I as a person
on Saturday that's what I'm talking about and
and got to separate you the person from you the
fighter yes because like the in suspended also
has helped me with you know I was suspended at
one point for almost two years for that steroid
thing so that helped me start to process John who
are you when you don't have the UFC to lean on
who are you and I've learned about myself that
I right away I find someone to work out with and
and that gets me off to college and you know and
then right now I have the cure project and it's
the first time in my life where I finally am a
part of something through this cure project is
is some so big for me it's it's like all I've
ever been my whole life is a father a man to my
girl Jesse a friend you know and like this this
UFC fighter I feel like my whole image has been
based around I've been John Jones Jon bones Jones
Jonny bones Jones I'm trying to create a life of
more substance outside the UFC I'm trying to get
to a place where I don't want to fight anymore or
I don't care about fighting anymore because we're
not getting validation from that and more I want
life that she's so powerful fulfilling outside
of UFC so that that if I do come back my ayat my
idea will be that I am truly giving them a gift
this is not for me this is you guys have paid me
enough to get me to come back and this is for this
is for like the fans of the sport but this isn't
something that I need to do anymore I want life
outside I want I want my friends to thank yo John
is the [ __ ] best friend to ever be friends with
I want I want my daughters to which they already
do absolutely love me and Amira me and respect
me I want my girl to look at me like yeah I got
the baddest [ __ ] man ever you know like that's
what that's what that's what that's where I'm
at right now it's like being the UFC champion
doesn't matter to nobody but but it's gonna call
it's really affect at the end of day me and my
circle right having money who does that affect
me and my kids right being an athlete don't mean
[ __ ] if you're not doing something with it
you're not in fact impacted somebody else and
some type of positive way our friends family and
and what really matters so the UFC MMA up and try
to get me back before I develop this identity that
has nothing to do with fighting and not want to go
back what I've noticed about you is I've always
seen you on you know on ESPN and I've had this
idea of you but like getting to know you over the
last couple days you're really [ __ ] funny dude
and in this care project deal the biggest thing
for me and you know spending this this the last
couple days with your with your crew man what of
the last couple days mr. Cruise trips been so epic
and I'm talking to your crew it's like everybody
who's involved in this care project these are the
people who are like a positive influence on you
yeah and I've heard it like you know I've heard
some of the guys say you know like man if if he
stays with this circle that you're this group of
people around him then like he can't go wrong you
know there but there is like some kind of other
element there's some kind of other crew yeah like
if you wander over and start with them it's kind
of all bad yeah I feel like the coronavirus in
my last DWI it the corona virus itself it changed
something in my psychology it just made me start
looking at everyone that I was hanging out with a
little differently I'm trying to look at like okay
I got a lot of buddies that I go to the bar with
and stuff and since the virus truck it just helped
me look at the people that I surround myself with
and ask me like okay you know what do I get out
of this friendship what is this doing you don't
need a corona virus to do that's what really
helped me though yeah it helped me it helped
me learn how to stay home on Fridays and Saturday
yeah you know I you know I I uh my wife she she
loves me to live the way I want you know pretty
much and she doesn't harass me about going out
and stuff like I had with my boys and stuff so and
so before the world got put on hold I you stopped
this fear of missing out I had to be how I had to
be at the party I had to be doing something that
I considered wild and fun and and coronavirus
really helped me realize that John you're not
missing anything out there and that everything
that really really matters is happening during the
daytime and in with your wife with your kids in
and coronavirus just really helped me detach from
the night life and now that it's reopening and you
know people are hitting me let's go here they open
here there's mad people on the patio over here and
now I've learned this lifestyle of accountability
partners and I'll have my strength coach you know
Garret meet up with me three days a week and then
I'll have my endurance coach Lawrence meet up with
me twice a week I don't know how my dog trainers
made up three days a week and then my family to do
these little date nights and my daughter's to box
two days a week and then before you know it you've
locked yourself in with so many sober people and
you can't you know so I I'm like I got like two or
three things to do almost every day with somebody
who's sober who that's a physical activity and I
don't have time I don't have time to be getting
hungover or doing stupid stuff right now and and
it's my accountability partners and my friends
close friends and coaches set me free and it got
me operating at closer to like a 80% level right
now when for the longest time I was operating at
90 percent in training camp and then I will go
back down to being about a 40 percent person [ __
] train I used to never train dude I used to just
man I just I was smoking ton of pot in between
fights get drunk on the weekends be going to
church on Sunday I love God with all my heart that
that's something that is very genuine about me
well yeah I had this side of me that just didn't
work hard or try hard at all I would only try hard
and camp in just being a loser man I was lucky I
was lucky that I didn't get in trouble more than I
actually did did get in trouble but right now I'm
opening up this this new idea in life I am busy
and I'm happy the first night that we met right
like you came to the green room at the show like
I'm a doing the [ __ ] show and the venue manager
says hey John Jones is here he's wondering if you
could come back and say hi I'm like what the
[ __ ] no way of course so John comes back we
hit it off we exchanged phone numbers and I'm
like yo dude let's beat up my ear tonight you
cauliflower ear it's on you we're gonna do it and
I'm like okay I gotta finish my meeting great but
then we'll meet up right and I mean like it's all
good but it seemed kind of evident to me that you
were with bad circle yeah yeah you know I know
everyone knows that but your sobriety and for a
while I felt like I surrounded myself with people
like to drink and smoke and and so out of respect
for you you know we took off but right now man
I'm at a place where I realized the responsibility
that I have the platform that I have and and I
realize that people respect you way more way more
for for what can you do for others for serving
then winning championships dude winning another
championship for Albuquerque like I do it for my
city I represent the board okay the 505 that's
nice what bro yeah donating half your endorsement
money to charities a month or and doing that type
of stuff is like I feel alive right now dude it's
like it makes you want to behave it makes you want
to keep that go on behaving for at behaving to
be the champ that's no pressure people expect a
world champion UFC fighter cage fighter to be a
little while you know but when you are the face
of a foundation about care it forces you to to
mature and to elevate yourself to a to a person
that is always on always on and always trying
to do the right thing so I'm excited to see what
I transition into over the next few years yeah I
mean especially with guys like you man who's just
the freakin former wild boy who's completely sober
now Matt wow this [ __ ] you always try to stop me
when I'm complimenting you the way the way that
you have changed your life bro and even seeing
your movie last night made me respect you so much
more birla just you went from such a I'll say dark
place man - just now you just [ __ ] you just
filled with a smile and and just you're trying
to use all that same fire and energy to change the
world for the better and I'm honored to be your
friend bro like I want to look at you as someone
as a mentor to people like Steve as a mentor
steve-o as John Jones is meant to I think I think
I think you'd be a good ear thank you so much and
I hope that you know any any part of this it was
like wasn't there wasn't any part of this there
was like rude or disrespectful or anything because
I have like so much respect when you were in the
pool yeah pull your shorts up all the way my wife
hates seeing your ass correct I could say - I love
you John John what a bitchin episode and you
know what else is really [ __ ] this signed
8 by 10 print of that building jump yeah they're
available already at Stevo comm so please head on
over there and get it because 100% of the revenue
is going straight to the Roadrunner Food Bank of
New Mexico Plus look right there that signature
looks just like a dick that's why I call it a
Ditka graph yeah and it's only 25 bucks which buys
up to a hundred and twenty five meals for hungry
New Mexicans so please do the right thing get
yourself this super dope signed 8 by 10 and you
know the street team I got I love you guys thank
you so much and yeah we'll see you next week Wow